robert buena noche gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 la
constitución de eeuu dice explícitamente
que el presidente debe nominar al
magistrado cuando haya una vacante cuál
es el argumento de los demócratas para
decir que se debe hacer después de estas
elecciones de noviembre
el argumento está en lo que ocurrió hace
cuatro años cuando mary carmen era el
juez que los demócratas querían nominar
a raíz de la muerte de anthony y salía
casualmente el que se considera el
mentor de la juez a ver quién es la que
está ahorita enfrentando los cee las
audiencias puesto que los republicanos
son los que impidieron esa nominación
del 2006 porque ellos argumentaban que
era año de elecciones ahora estamos en
el 2020 la muerte de jeans porque
ocurrió hace semanas y ellos quieren
hacer este proceso lo más ágil posible y
que probablemente se les vaya a dar ese
es el argumento de los demócratas de que
los republicanos no cumplieron con su
palabra de esperar la nominación hasta
que un nuevo presidente asuma el cargo y
ese es el argumento que ellos están
presionando además del hecho de que esta
señora tiene digamos un récord un
historial de oponerse a planes como
robbie wait que es el que le permite el
aborto a las mujeres de manera legal
el obamacare que es el el servicio
médico asequible que fue inaugurado
precisamente durante la administración
de barack obama sip robert está ya
implícito que va a ver será nominada
debido a la mayoría republicana en el
senado o puede no salir confirmada no es
prácticamente seguro pues ellos tienen
la mayoría en el senado y aunque puestos
estadounidenses han estado un poco
divididos frente al tema 48 por ciento
de ellos indican que no se debe hacer
una nominación
antes de las elecciones de 3 noviembre
46% dicen que sí según una encuesta de
cnn pero indudablemente los republicanos
están más que dispuestos a nominar la
muy a pesar de la oposición que tienen
los demócratas y bueno lo que acaba de
mencionar muy a pesar de lo que opinen
los estadounidenses esto se va a dar sí
o sí ahora una última pregunta
robert d va a haber tiene los méritos
necesarios para estar en la corte
suprema podría enfrentar alguna
controversia
bueno ella tiene los digamos los
pergaminos y esto lo esto se ha
discutido anteriormente tanto por un
lado por el otro los jueces colegas
algunos han dicho que ella tiene los
requisitos otros dicen que no y yo creo
que el argumento aquí básicamente su
oposición frente al seguro médico
asequible y a los derechos reproductivos
de la mujer el tema judicial
lamentablemente tiene un tinte político
que no debería ser realmente y eso es el
argumento que van a hacer los demócratas
el hecho de que ella podría presentar
esa exención a que se mantengan estos
estos derechos